between 70 and 200 000 people dead more
than 250 000 injured 1.5 million
homeless on this day the 18th of January
2010 this is the sad toll of the
devastating earthquake in Haiti the
European commission through its
humanitarian aid department has acted
quickly by allocating a budget of 30
million euros to its humanitarian
Partners deployed in the field each
organization is using its knowledge and
experience to respond to the devastation
caused by the earthquake
here is an account by midsandu Maude
they're all like that they stay days and
days some with limbs completely lost
alive with makeshift bandages and
waiting for surgery it's a fact we can't
operate them all at the same time we
have to do it one at a time and that
isn't quick
the five other organizations financed by
the European commission are the world
food program The Finnish and German Red
Cross Oxfam UK and Telecom song Frontier
many of echo's humanitarian Partners
already working in Haiti before the
earthquake have lost members of their
staff in addition most of their
installations have been damaged or
destroyed despite these problems Aid is
getting through
imagine yourself you lost everything and
moreover you can't you can't even say to
your family that you're alive
that's why it's so important for those
people they just come here the first
message is to say I'm alive I'm okay
don't worry well the house is down then
they start they stop the bad news
because of course there's always bad
news it's very emotional moments and
then sometimes they cry they shout they
when they come to saying that is dead
our brothers didn't made it it's very
emotive moment so I think it's important
because for them they face the trauma
and the fact that they can speak to to a
loved one and it's like I would compare
to like a psychological support speaking
and it's releasing a weight that they
have with them that's why I think it's a
very important service
they ask news of all my family I said
that all the family is fine no problem
all our things are ruined that's the way
it is thank God we're alive and we're
here life continues for us life
continues